[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen guten Abend an diesem Europatag
der den Moment am 9 mai 1950 markiert
als der Vorschlag gemacht wurde die
deutsche und französische Kohle und
Stahlproduktion nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg zusammenzulegen woraus später
eine europäische Gemeinschaft für Kohle
und Stahl wurde woraus später die EU
wurde wie der Bundeskanzler sie heute in
Straßburg vorfindet Olaf Scholz
appelliert dort an das Europaparlament
und an eine EU die vor massiven
Herausforderungen steht und auch von
Deutschland erwartet dass es seine
Hausaufgaben macht eine EU die keine
gemeinsame asyl- und Migrationspolitik
zustande bringt und dabei auch Richtung
Deutschland guckt wo in der Frage morgen
ein heftiger Streit zwischen Bund und
Bundesländern gelöst werden
müsste kann man sagen hier ist unser
europakarosponent ultra
wenn man sich die Länge des roten
Teppichs ansah dann schienen die
Erwartungen hoch Auftritt Olaf Scholz
der steht innenpolitisch wegen der
flüchtlingsdiskussion unter Druck beim
Treffen mit Parlamentspräsidentin mizola
gibt sich Scholz zuversichtlich dass
Europa eine Antwort findet dazu gehört
natürlich auch ein wirksamer Grenzschutz
an den europäischen Außengrenzen der
notwendig ist dazu gehört aber auch
einen gemeinsamer Umgang mit
Flüchtlingen finden wir keine Lösung
dann werden die Bürger nicht mehr nach
Europa für Lösungen schauen
der Tag begann ganz höflich für Scholz
freundlicher Beifall für einen von dem
sich viele mehr Führung wünschen bei der
Debatte um die Bewaffnung der Ukraine
wirkte stolz zögerlich umso klarer seine
Botschaft in Richtung Moskau
[Applaus]
2200 Kilometer nordöstlich von hier in
Moskau des Putin heute seine Soldaten
Panzer und Raketen auf marschieren
lassen wir uns nicht einschüchtern von
solchen Macht gehabt
bleiben wir standhaft in der Aussprache
fiel der Kopfhörer von Scholz aus aber
eigentlich braucht er ihn gar nicht dass
EU-Parlament wandelte sich zum Bundestag
die deutschen Abgeordneten Namen den
Kanzler ins Visier selbst sein eigener
Koalitionspartner
[Applaus]
Kanzlei
sie mit ihnen ange
HT vielen Stellen hier in Brüssel und
Straßburg häufig so und in vielen
Hauptstädten der Europäischen Union als
müsste man ihn jede konkrete Maßnahme
mühsam abbringen wir brauchen keine
weiteren grundsatzreden mehr wir
brauchen jetzt den Mut Europa in die
Zukunft zu führen europa braucht Führung
Führung braucht es auch bei einem
anderen großen Thema die
flüchtlingskrise Scholz weiß auch hier
es braucht eine europäische Lösung er
sucht nach Gemeinsamkeiten in einer
Frage die seit Jahren umstritten ist uns
einfach das Ziel
erreguläre Migration besser zu steuern
und zuordnen ohne unsere Werte zu
verraten dann ein genervter Kanzler
diesmal weiß nicht der Kopfhörer diesmal
nervten ihn die Nationalkonservativen im
Parlament sie wollen keinen Kompromiss
in der Flüchtlingsfrage stattdessen
sprechen sie von deutscher schuld
auf meine sins von den vielen Sünden die
die Deutschen begangen haben ist eine
die schlimmste die Öffnung der Grenzen
während der flüchtlingskrise
am Ende ein paar versöhnliche Momente
der Kanzler fährt wieder zurück nach
Berlin mit ihm reist die ungelöste
Flüchtlingsfrage Europa weiß auch keine
Antwort
und hier ist der Bundesfinanzminister
bezahlen muss er am Ende nicht
persönlich aber eben über das Geld
entscheiden guten Abend Christian
Lindner einen schönen guten Abend ich
grüße sie der Bundeskanzler hofft heute
in Straßburg dass die EU ihre Asyl und
Migrationspolitik reformiert reicht
Hoffnung und wie viel Hoffnung haben Sie
denn da angesichts der Erfahrungen aus
der Vergangenheit
Hoffnung wird nicht reichen sondern wir
brauchen Taten und die beginnen in
Deutschland wir haben seit vielen Jahren
nicht die Kontrolle über die Zuwanderung
nach Deutschland die wir brauchen kurz
gesagt wir haben es zu lange den
Menschen schwer gemacht nach Deutschland
zu kommen die wir brauchen als kluge
Köpfe und fleißige Hände und zu lange
schon machen wir den Menschen es leicht
zu bleiben die eigentlich verpflichtet
sind auszureisen weil sie irregulär nach
Deutschland eingereist sind und das muss
sich ändern umgekehrt wäre besser
leichtere qualifizierte Einwanderung und
Verhinderung irregulärer Migration das
klingt jetzt erstmal nach einem
Schlagwort dann ein weiteres dass die
FDP insbesondere jetzt in die Diskussion
bringt ist das von der Zeitenwende viel
strapaziertes Wort zeitenwände jetzt
auch in der migrations- und Asylpolitik
in Deutschland wird gefordert aber Herr
Lindner was soll das konkret halten
das bedeutet konkret erstens dass wir
uns bekennen zum Schutz der Außengrenzen
der Europäischen Union notfalls auch mit
Zäunen es bedeutet zweitens dass wir bei
der Abschiebung von Menschen die kein
dauerhaftes Aufenthaltsrecht in
Deutschland haben ernst machen da
wirksamer werden dazu hilft es auch mehr
Länder zu sogenannten sicheren
Herkunftsländern zu erklären in die man
ohne aufwendiges Asylverfahren
zurückschicken kann es bedeutet dass
Länder erwägen statt
Geldleistungen Sachleistungen für
diejenigen die im Asylverfahren sind zu
gewähren also alle Maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen die Kontrolle des Zugangs nach
Deutschland zu verbessern müssen jetzt
eingeleitet werden wir können nicht
immer versuchen das Problem die
Herausforderung mit Geld zu lösen wir
müssen an die Quelle des Problems und
das bedeutet irreguläre Migration nach
Deutschland muss reduziert werden das
haben schon andere versucht das hat
bisher so noch nicht funktioniert naja
in Europa versucht man das schon
diskutiert das schon seit Jahrzehnten
mittlerweile
wie man sich das dann ganz konkret
vorstellt klar ist aber eins ich glaube
darauf können wir uns auf jeden Fall
einigen es ist zumindest nichts was die
aktuelle Lage in Deutschland verbessert
oder erleichtern wird insofern bleibt es
erstmal Zukunftsmusik und bei dem
aktuellen
Problemen jetzt können wir gerne
widersprechen
ich will sie gar nicht unterbrechen aber
muss es doch weil sie als eine Tatsache
herstellen und er darstellen und ich
muss Ihnen sagen zum einen nein über
ganz viele Jahre unter CDU Führung und
mit einem CSU Innenminister wurde eben
nicht alles getan um die Rückführung zu
erleichtern und an Deutschland ist der
Schutz der europäischen Außengrenze über
viele Jahre gescheitert gut und zum
anderen natürlich
endlich Ausreise Verpflichtungen die wir
haben zu vollziehen das entlastet unsere
gegenwärtige Situation zweifelsohne ein
CSU-Innenminister wie Horst Seehofer hat
aber sich so ähnlich oder praktisch
genauso angehört wie sie gerade hat es
dann aber bloß am Ende nicht umsetzen
können das zeigt er wie schwer das ganze
ist auch mit ihrem Koalitionspartner zum
Beispiel den Grünen aber ich möchte
jetzt doch noch mal einen Schritt weiter
gehen und auf die aktuelle Situation
eingehen in der sie als
verteidigungsverteidigung sage ich schon
als Finanzminister ganz konkret
gefordert sind es gibt alarmierende
Hilferufe Herr Lindner aus den Gemeinden
und Städten wollen sie am Ende wirklich
der sein der sagt damit müsst ihr jetzt
selbst klar kommen auch wenn viel mehr
Flüchtlinge zu uns kommen mehr Geld
gibt's von uns im Bund nicht
es kann überhaupt gar keine Rede davon
sein dass die Länder und die Gemeinden
auf sich alleine gestellt werden dass
Bundeskabinett wird morgen einen Bericht
verabschieden wo wir mal die Zahlen
dargelegt haben etwa 16 Milliarden Euro
wendet der Bund auf im Bereich der
Migration wir haben bei den geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine als Bund komplett jetzt
den Lebensunterhalt in die Finanzierung
des Bundes übernommen das sogenannte
Bürgergeld es kann keine Rede davon sein
dass der Bund andere staatliche Ebenen
allein lässt aber aber
unterbrechen an der Stelle weil nämlich
die Länder genau das Gegenteil sagen die
Länder sagen ihre Berechnung ja die
Zahlen sprechen für sich sagen sie haben
gestern den Vorgespräch in der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hier in der
Sendung gehabt Stefan weil aus
Niedersachsen der sagt unsere besten
zahlenexperten sitzen da dran und was
der Bund da ausgerechnet hat stimmt
schlecht nicht das können wir
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch wir
beide jetzt hier heute Abend hier nicht
aufdrösel und auflösen deswegen die
Frage was bleibt am Ende ja der Eindruck
dass die Politik dieses Problem
offensichtlich nicht lösen kann
das ist ja genau das was wir gerade
besprechen es soll immer über die
Finanzierung des Problems gesprochen
werden und die Bundesregierung hat jetzt
entschieden wir wollen über das Problem
selbst sprechen und ich muss Ihnen
leider widersprechen mein Eindruck ist
nicht dass die frühere Bundesregierung
Unterführung der Bundeskanzlerin Merkel
und mit einem CSU Innenminister dass die
wirklich ernst gemacht haben bei der
Unterbindung irregulärer Migration es
ist diese Bundesregierung der ich
angehöre die erstmals ein
Sonderbeauftragten eingesetzt hat um zu
sprechen mit Herkunftsländern über die
Rücknahme von Menschen die sich nicht
legal in Deutschland aufhalten wir
sprechen jetzt konkret über neue
Herkunftsländer um
Asylverfahren zu vermeiden und schneller
Menschen zurückzuschicken und deshalb
muss darauf bestehen es kann nicht immer
nur um die Finanzierung von Migration
gehen solange wir keine Kontrolle haben
wir brauchen endlich
anderes System der Einwanderung nach
Deutschland
qualifizierten muss es leichter werden
ihre reguläre Migration müssen wir
konsequent unterbinden lassen sie noch
kurz über ein anderes Thema reden sie
sind kurz vor einer Asien Reise Herr
Lindner jetzt hat die chinesischer
Kollege plötzlich entdeckt dass er für
sie keine Zeit mehr hat wie sehr trifft
sie das
ich sehe das gelassen angeblich sind es
technische Gründe die dazu geführt haben
da kann sich jeder ein Bild machen klar
ist jedenfalls 1 die Politik der
Bundesregierung ist von
kalenderproblemen nicht beeinflussbar
wir sehen realistischerweise China als
ein wichtiges gegenüber im Handel das
muss man auch ohne Naivität sagen auf
der anderen Seite irgendwelche
Terminverschiebungen ändern nichts daran
dass wir uns einsetzen für das
Völkerrecht für Menschenrechte und für
eine liberale Demokratie wie Tai waren
sag Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch aber gerne
und wir haben das Interview aus Termin
Gründen vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet es
ist in voller Länge online auf ZDF heute
und während der deutsche Finanzminister
also erstmal seine China-Reise streichen
muss ist Chinas Außenminister in Berlin
ein Besuch bei dem auch alle
diplomatischen Floskeln nicht verdecken
können wie sehr es knirscht zwischen
Berlin und Peking speziell wenn es um
die Haltung zu Russland geht Thomas
Reichert
Chinas Außenminister ist früh dran an
diesen Mittag zu früh weshalb seine
Kolonne kurz vor dem Auswärtigen Amt
hält und brav wartet wer immer glaubte
Peking könnte beleidigt sein nach dem
Kontroversen China Besuch der
Außenministerin vor gut drei Wochen der
sieht sich getäuscht china hat es sogar
besonders eilig mit den Wiedersehen denn
Chinas Außenminister chingang will etwas
von Berlin von bärburg vor allem mehr
Handel was in alarmiert weniger Handel
weniger Abhängigkeit
wenn man im Namen von die Wrestling
jetzt die Entkopplung von China umsetzt
dann bedeutet das eigentlich auch eine
Beseitigung oder Entfernung von Chancen
von Stabilität und Entwicklung
etwa zur gleichen Zeit geht es im
Theater der Ruhrfestspiele in
Recklinghausen um ganz ähnliche Fragen
erzielte Peter Proben für die Premiere
eine Stückes über Unterdrückung in China
Nachbarin der einen chinesischen
offiziellen später 2006 versucht sich
aus Protest selbst anzuzünden die
Menschen in Tibet Hongkong und Ching
Chang bräuchten Unterstützung von
Ländern wie Deutschland sagte aber
können sie helfen
sie sind wirtschaftlich immer von China
abhängig wir fordern dass wir als
Maßstab des Handelns Menschlichkeit
wichtiger nehmen als die Wirtschaft
auch in Berlin verlangt bärburg von
China die Einhaltung der Menschenrechte
chingang verbietet sich die Einmischung
in die inneren Angelegenheiten Chinas
wer Bock fordert China solle
einflussnehmer Russland damit es sich
aus der Ukraine zurückzieht schönen
entgegnet beide Seiten sollten den Krieg
beenden und dann droht bärbock mit EU
Sanktion gegen chinesische Firmen die im
Verdacht stehen Kriegswaffen taugliches
Material an Russland zu liefern das
richtet sich nicht gegen irgendein
spezifisches Land sondern das bezieht
sich speziell auf diese sanktionierten
Güter wir erwarten aber von allen
Ländern wir erwarten auch von China dass
es auf seine Firmen in dem Sinne
entsprechend einwirkt china steht
versprochen
Waffen zu liefern im Fall von Sanktionen
droht es nun
momentan wir sind strikt dagegen dass
manche Länder nach ihren eigenen
inländischen Gesetzen einseitige
Sanktionen gegen China einleiten und
wenn das der Fall wäre würden wir auch
strikt und streng darauf reagieren
gesehen gibt es noch viel zu besprechen
schönen Tag noch in der Tat gibt es das
in gut einem Monat wird Gin deshalb
schon wieder in Berlin sein zu deutsch
chinesischen Regierungskonsultationen
der Chef der russischen Söldnertruppe
Wagner ist zu einem Präsidenten heute in
die Parade gefahren und zwar im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes während Wladimir Putin
auf dem Roten Platz den traditionellen
militäraufmarsch zum Jahrestag des Siegs
über Nazi Deutschland abnimmt meldet
sich Evgeni brigoschin und beschuldigt
eine russische armeeeinheit vor Kämpfen
in der Ukraine geflohen zu sein schuld
sei die Zitat Dummheit der russischen
Heeresführung der Fisch stinkt vom Kopf
her auch das ist ein bregorien Zitat der
Kopf des russischen Staates kämpft nicht
nur seinen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine erkämpft offenbar auch intern
und dieser 9 mai in Moskau fiel dann
auch merkwürdig anders aus als sonst
Sebastian eben jetzt mit mehr
die Parade ist in Moskau heute
allgegenwärtig auch in der Metro oben
sind die Straßen gesperrt und so waren
auch die Offiziere mit der Ringbahn
bei bestem Wetter drängen sich an der
Moskva die Schaulustigen der sogenannte
Tag des Sieges ist hier vielen wichtig
die Meinung zum Krieg gespalten
wenn es sollte keinen Krieg geben er ist
nicht richtig für mich ist die Parade
aber ein großer tiefer unglaublicher
Respekt und Dankbarkeit gegenüber meinen
Vorfahren die es mir ermöglicht haben
jetzt hier zu sein
vor Beginn der militärischen
spezialoperation gab es keine solche
Spaltung in der Gesellschaft deswegen
ist die Parade heute wichtiger denn je
um 10 Uhr Ortszeit beginnt auf dem Roten
Platz die große Propaganda Show des
Wladimir Putin der will mit der Parade
jedes Jahr ein Bild der russischen
Stärke und Überlegenheit in die Welt
schicken heute 15 Monate nach dem
russischen Einmarsch spricht Putin sehr
offen von einem Krieg seine Lesart
Russland Kämpfe gegen den Westen und die
Nato und führe eine
verteidigungsschlacht
es wurde ein echter Krieg gegen unser
Vaterland entfesselt aber wir haben den
internationalen Terrorismus eine Abfuhr
erteilt wir werden die Bewohner des
Schützen und unsere Sicherheit
gewährleisten
die Parade selbst ist eine Aufführung
auf Sparflamme nur ein sowjetischer T34
Panzer rollt über den Roten Platz
modernere T90 wie letztes Jahr sucht man
vergeblich auch eine Flugshow der
Luftwaffe trotz besten Wetters
Fehlanzeige und die Zahl der Soldaten
ist mit 8000 Mann deutlich geringer als
sonst
und während sich Putin eigentlich für
sein Militär feiern lassen wollte
beleidigt der Chef der Wagner Söldner
Jewgeni pregorcin mit einem neuerlichen
Wutausbruch die militärische Führung des
Landes
ein Soldat darf nicht wegen der
absoluten Dummheit seiner
kommandierenden sterben und die Generäle
und Oberleutnants vor Ort müssen diese
Dummheiten ausführen die Befehle die von
oben kommen sind absolut kriminell
bist du
um 22 Uhr Ortszeit sendet das
Staatsfernsehen gewaltige Feuerwerke aus
dem ganzen Land doch die Feierlichkeiten
können die vielen Misstöne der
vergangenen Tage nicht überdecken es
wirkte zuletzt als entgleute der
russischen Führung die Kontrolle die
Parade heute hat nicht dazu beigetragen
diesem Gefühl etwas entgegenzusetzen
also kein Zeichen russischer Stärke das
kann ja eigentlich nicht im Interesse
von Präsident Putin sein für begangen
ist unsere Korrespondentin in Moskau
guten Abend für wieso kam es jetzt so
waren das tatsächlich Sicherheitsgründe
also wenn Präsident Putin von
irgendwoher ein Signal der Stärke
braucht dann ist es wohl von der Front
in der Ukraine oder wie ein
regime-treuer Politologe das heute
Mittag auf Telegramm formulierte es ist
Zeit für Wort für Taten und nicht für
Worte die russischen
Patrioten die warteten so formulierte
ist dieser ehemalige Redenschreiber des
Kreml weiter die warteten darauf
herauszufinden obladimir Putin denn
aussah reden noch etwas anderes könne
die Drohnenangriffe der letzten Wochen
die Explosionen an Bahnschienen und an
öldepots zuletzt am Samstag das
versuchte Attentat mit einer Autobombe
auf einen russischen Nationalisten Alter
das zeigt dass der Krieg in der Ukraine
auch Auswirkungen auf die
Sicherheitslage in Russland hat und das
ist ein Eindruck der lange Zeit
unbedingt vermieden werden sollte vor
diesem Hintergrund wünschen sich ein
großer Teil der russischen Bevölkerung
sicherlich eher Erfolge an der Front als
eben große Symbolik und so mag die
Sicherheitslage ein Grund für die etwas
kleinere Parade heute gewesen sein an
anderer könnte aber durchaus der sein
dass das Verteidigungsministerium sich
der Kritik entziehen wollte dass es
Waffentechnik die woanders viel
dringender gebraucht wird über den Roten
Platz fährt für life aus Moskau vielen
Dank für deine Einschätzung heute Abend
so und jetzt gucken wir in die Ukraine
und tun das mit Diana anlässlich des
heutigen europatags ist
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
nach Kiew gereist um den ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski zu Gesprächen zu
treffen im Anschluss sagte von der Leyen
die Ukraine gehöre zur europäischen
Familie und lobte die Bemühungen Kiews
mit Blick auf die angestrebten
eu-beitrittsgespräche selenski
bekräftigte in der gemeinsamen
Pressekonferenz seine Forderung nach
schnellen munitionslieferungen
in Deutschland soll es in Zukunft
leichter werden sein Geschlecht und
seinen Vornamen im
Personenstandsregister zu ändern den
Gesetzentwurf dazu haben heute
Familienministerin Paulus und
Justizminister Buschmann vorgestellt
künftig soll für Erwachsene eine
einfache Erklärung beim Standesamt
ausreichen um den geschlechtseintrag
abzuändern das bisher nötige
Gerichtsverfahren entfällt zudem ist es
nicht mehr nötig ein ärztliches Attest
und Gutachten vorzulegen gerade das war
von vielen Betroffenen als entwürdigend
empfunden worden
das geplante heizungsgesetz sorgt weiter
für Diskussionen dieses Mal im Fokus der
Startzeitpunkt nach bisherigen Plänen
soll das Gesetz zum Einbau
klimafreundlicher Heizungen ab Januar
2024 in Kraft treten Zeiten
Wirtschaftsverbände allerdings für nicht
umsetzbar der heizungsverband plädiert
für eine Verschiebung des Gesetzes unter
anderem wegen Fachkräftemangels und noch
unklarer Förderungen ähnlich äußerte
sich die deutsche Industrie und
Handelskammer
im Nahen Osten wächst die Sorge vor
einer neuen Eskalation der Gewalt
zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern das
israelische Militär hat bei
Luftangriffen im Gazastreifen unter
anderem drei ranghohe Anführer einer
militanten Palästinenserorganisation
getötet allerdings kam dabei auch Kinder
und weitere Unbeteiligte ums Leben
Israels premier Natan Yahoo sagte die
Militäraktionen seien eine Reaktion auf
die palästinensischen Raketenangriffe in
der vergangenen Woche die Organisation
islamischer Jihad kündigte ihrerseits
Vergeltung an
ja gefährliche Situation mal wieder im
Nahen Osten und dann ist vor ein paar
Minuten der Zivilprozess gegen Donald
Trump wegen Vergewaltigungsvorwürfen zu
Ende gegangen in New York Johannes
Hannover verfolgt das für uns guten
Abend Johannes wie sieht das Urteil aus
also die Jury bestehend aus sechs Männer
und drei Frauen hat Donald Trump wegen
sexuellen Missbrauchs und Verleumdung zu
einer Schadensersatzzahlung von 5
Millionen Dollar verurteilt
strafrechtlich konnte er nicht mehr
belangt werden das war verjährt aber
hier New York hat man die zivilrechtlich
die Verjährungsfrist ausgesetzt für ein
Jahr um den Frauen das hat man während
der mito-bewegung gemerkt und der
Verfahren gegen Haribo Steen um Frauen
die sich bislang nicht getraut haben
nach vorne zu gehen um ihre Opfer zu
konfrontieren die Chance zu geben auf
einen ordentliches Verfahren
IG Carol hat das gemacht sie hat ja
behauptet sie sei von Donald Trump in
den 90er Jahren in einer Umkleidekabine
in einem Luxuskaufhaus vergewaltigt
worden und sie hat sich damit vor einer
Jury jetzt durchsetzen können und wir
sehen sie auch gerade in den Bildern die
sie aus dem Gerichtssaal heute rauskommt
Johannes es gibt auch erste Reaktionen
gerade eben von Donald Trump für ein
Wort dass man von ihm kennt er sagt dass
Urteil ist das Grace kann man denn schon
absehen was das bedeutet für seine
Ambitionen auf eine erneute
Präsidentschaft
also bislang ist ein Donald Trump ja
alles abgetropft oder hat er alles
abtropfen lassen seine kernwählerschaft
steht geschlossen zu ihm der wird auch
dieses Urteil wohl nichts daran ändern
aber man muss schon darauf achten wie
sich jetzt vor einigen das bürgerliche
Publikum in den vorstehenden entscheide
da hat er aber den letzten Wahlen kein
besonders gutes Standing und es wird
sich auch durch jetzt dieses Urteil
nicht wahrscheinlich nicht verbessern
interessant wird auch sein wie sich die
Republikaner jetzt aufstellen werden
denn es ist schon schwierig für sie mit
einem Kandidaten möglicherweise ins
Rennen zu gehen der wegen sexuellen
Missbrauchs verurteilt worden ist ich
glaube du willst jetzt in den nächsten
Tagen sehr intensive Diskussion geben
Johannes vielen Dank für diese ganz
aktuellen Einschätzungen live aus New
York und damit gehen wir in diese
Sendung zurück zu uns hier nach
Deutschland eine
Kriminalstatistik gibt die erfassten
Fälle wieder also die die Behörden
verfolgt haben das muss man wissen das
macht Vergleiche nicht immer einfach die
tatsächlichen Fälle können davon
abweichen und dennoch bleibt so eine
Statistik ein wichtiger Gradmesser und
deshalb hören wir heute hin wenn
Innenministerium und bundeskriminal
bekommt einen Höchststand an politisch
motivierten Straftaten melden seit
Einführung dieser Statistik vor mehr als
20 Jahren knapp 60.000 Delikte im
vergangenen Jahr besonders auffällig der
Anstieg von rechtsextremistisch
motivierten Straftaten und
rechtsextremistischer Gewalt die war für
rund 41 Prozent aller erfassten Opfer
politisch motivierter Gewalt
verantwortlich Nicola Albrecht jetzt aus
Brandenburg wo gleich mehrere Vorfälle
an Schulen für Aufregung sorgen
nur eine Handvoll Bürger Lehrer und
Schüler sind heute hierher vor das
Schulamt in Cottbus gekommen um ein
Zeichen gegen Rechtsextreme Vorfälle in
der Region und besonders an Schulen zu
setzen sie seien mit ihrer Haltung
inzwischen in der Minderheit und das
müsse aufhören so ihr Tenor Schule ist
meines Abbild der Gesellschaft und wenn
die Gesellschaft mit Hakenkreuzen
versehen ist dann haben wir ein Problem
das hatten wir schon mal Diskriminierung
vor allem Rassismus und Antisemitismus
beispielsweise sind eigentlich
alltäglich und das äußert sich dann so
offen posieren Schüler mit Hitler groß
auf dem Sportplatz der Gemeinde Burg im
Spreewald in ihrer Schule Hakenkreuze an
den Wänden Nazi Parolen auf Schule iPads
und den chatgruppen publik gemacht
hatten dies Jungs zwei Lehrer in einem
anonymen Brandbrief erst danach hat die
Schulleitung die Vorfälle angezeigt
warum so lange geschwiegen wurde
verwundert Beobachter nicht
es wäre viel zu kurz gegriffen jetzt das
Problem allein bei den Jugendlichen und
den Kindern zu suchen es muss immer
geschaut werden wo es herkommt und
gerade wenn wir uns jetzt die Region
über die wir gerade reden zum Beispiel
im Spreewald der anschauen da gibt es
eine lebhafte rechtsextreme Szene und
die dort leben und diese Szene bilden
das sind die Eltern dieser Jugendlichen
ja dieser Rechtsextremismus der wird
vererbt ja der wird eben nicht
konsequent aufgearbeitet der wurde seit
den 90er Jahren nicht konsequent
aufgearbeitet und wurde eben auch nicht
genügend tabuisiert und Burg ist
offenbar kein Einzelfall am vergangenen
Wochenende sollen Berliner Schüler mit
Migrationshintergrund auf einer
Klassenfahrt hier im Landschulheim am
brandenburgischen Frauensee rassistisch
angefeindet und bedroht worden sein die
Schüler fuhren aus Angst noch in der
Nacht zurück nach Berlin Schulterzucken
bei dem ein oder anderen Anwohner
ich halte mich da raus ist auch da nicht
viel zu nach ich mach mein Ding und
alles ist gut nun ermittelt der
Staatsschutz wegen Volksverhetzung und
Bedrohung Brandenburgs Regierung zeigt
sich geschockt und verspricht Aufklärung
doch Aufklärung und die üblichen
Beratungsangebote werden angesichts der
Lage allein nicht reichen meint der
Leiter des Brandenburgischen
Verfassungsschutzes alle Akteure Seins
Eltern Seins Schüler Seins Lehrer sei es
die Stadt sei es der Verfassungsschutz
die Polizei müssen an einen Tisch kommen
möglichst schnell das heißt wir müssen
uns ein Problem stellen und eine
Beratung
eine Betreuung Schule Sozialarbeit
allein wird es nicht reichen wir müssen
sanktionieren wir müssen zeigen dass das
nicht toleriert wird vor Ort wenn jemand
außerhalb der Demokratie
rechtsextremistische Parolen schreibt
während die einen für Demokratie und
Vielfalt demonstrieren tauchen
unterdessen vor der Schule in Burg
Mitglieder der neonazistischen
Kleinpartei der dritte Weg auf verteilen
Flugblätter und umwerben die Schüler
es geht ihnen um nicht mehr und nicht
weniger als ihr Denken zu bestimmen
so jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema hier bei
uns aus der Wirtschaft und das machst du
Hannah ja genau wir blicken
auf es heute bei der Hauptversammlung
ziemlich viel Gegenwind für den Kurs von
Vorstandsvorsitzenden Sport kritisiert
wurde unter anderem dass die
lufthansa-familie immer weiter wächst
und schon bald noch eine weitere Airline
dazu kommen soll Frank Bethmann warum
sehen die Aktionäre das so kritisch mit
der italienischen ita der früheren
Alitalia will die Lufthansa jetzt die 12
der Airline Marke in den Konzernverbund
holen da sagen inzwischen etliche
Aktionärsvertreter allmählich wird die
Lufthansa zum gemischt waren Laden Swiss
Austrian Airlines Eurowings wofür steht
die Fluggesellschaft eigentlich noch ist
sie mir ein Premium oder doch ein billig
Anbieter und es gibt Zweifel ob sich mit
immer mehr Marken der Konzern überhaupt
noch erfolgreich lenken lässt Lufthansa
Chef sport hält dagegen sagt diese mehr
Markenstrategie war vor Corona richtig
und sie ist es selbstverständlich auch
immer noch klar ist die Lufthansa
expandiert weil sie im internationalen
Wettbewerb weiter wachsen will
in die Marktmacht der Lufthansa wächst
was bedeutet das denn am Ende für die
Passagiere also für die Ticketpreise ja
man merkt es ja jetzt schon die
Ticketpreise haben angezogen fliegen es
deutlich teurer als vor drei vier Jahren
geworden der Lufthansa gelingt es
derzeit durch ihre Stärke am Markt
höhere Preise durchzusetzen insbesondere
das Sommergeschäft boomt und so freuten
sich die Aktionärsvertreter heute zwar
darüber dass ich die Airline Gruppe im
Aufwind befinde gleichzeitig warnten
andere dass die steigende Markt macht
der Lufthansa Gruppe nicht zulasten der
Kunden gehen dürfe genau danach aber
sieht es im Augenblick aus vielen Dank
Frank für deine Einschätzung
die Zahl der berufstätigen Frauen die
kleinen Kinder haben ist in den
vergangenen Jahren deutlich gestiegen
sie liegt allerdings weiterhin sehr viel
niedriger als die der berufstätigen
Väter laut Statistischen Bundesamt
hatten im vergangenen Jahr knapp 40% der
Frauen mit Kindern unter drei Jahren
einen Job 2008 lag der Anteil bei knapp
31%
. als Grund nennen die Statistiker einen
Ausbau der Krippen und Kita-Plätze bei
den Vätern blieb der Anteil fast
unverändert und lag zuletzt bei neuen
80,6%
in vielen kommunalen Kliniken in
Deutschland gab es heute nur eine
Grundversorgung denn die Gewerkschaft
Marburger Bund hatte erneut zum
Warnstreik aufgerufen bundesweit legten
tausende Ärztinnen und Ärzte ihre Arbeit
nieder sie fordern 2,5% mehr Lohn und
einen Inflationsausgleich die nächste
Verhandlungsrunde ist für den 22 Mai
vorgesehen
der Fußball-Bundesliga ist Eintracht
Frankfurt trennt sich von seinem Trainer
Oliver Glasner das gab der Verein am
Abend bekannt demnach werden die
Eintracht und glasna zum Saisonende
getrennte Wege gehen in den letzten zehn
Bundesligaspielen blieb der Club ohne
einen Sieg allerdings steht der am 3
juni im DFB-Pokalfinale
ja viel passiert heute wir danken für
Ihr Interesse und sagen gerne bis morgen
aber erst noch dieser wichtige Hinweis
gegen 0 Uhr Christopher Wehrmann mit
unserem heute journal Update und wir
alle hier sagen bis morgen schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend zwischen zwei hoch ist Platz
für ties da steigt der
Grundwasserspiegel und die
Waldbrandgefahr sinkt heute gab es
zunächst eine Schauer Staffel hier im
Westen Deutschlands und dann setzte am
Nachmittag kräftiger Dauerregen von
besten ein und dieses Regenband holte
die Schauer mehr und mehr ein jetzt im
Laufe der Nacht zieht dieses Regenband
weiter nach Osten und an den Alpen setzt
Dauerregen ein dieses regenrad wird
morgen über Tag in die Länge gezogen und
westlich davon entwickeln sich weitere
Schauer und auch Gewitter und am
Alpenrand kommt die Schneefallgrenze
etwas runter am ehesten klar ist es
heute Nacht hier im Nordosten und am
Alpenrand in den Mittelgebirgen und im
Nordosten sinken die Temperaturen auf 8
bis 6 Grad sonst NAT die Nacht bei 12
bis 9 Grad milder morgen erwarten uns
dann Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 12 Grad
am Alpenrand und 22 Grad in der
Uckermark am freundlichsten ist es
morgen zwischen der ist und der
Ostseeküste sonst aber fällt viel Regen
und dieser Regen ist oft mit Gewittern
durchsetzt die Sonne werden sie
zwischendurch auch mal zu Gesicht
bekommen am ehesten trockenen
Süddeutschland ist es Richtung Saarland
in der Pfalz oder auch in Schwaben und
der kräftige Dauerregen hier zwischen
dem Allgäu und dem Berchtesgadener Land
lässt nur vorübergehen nach zum
Wochenende wird es dann von Norden
allmählich sonniger und dort dann auch
wieder recht mild und wenn Sie sich
jetzt fragen wie viel Regen denn da wohl
runterkommt bis Freitag früh sind das
hier in Oberitalien aber auch in Istrien
bis zu 80 am Alpenrand bis zu 60 Liter
pro Quadratmeter guten Abend